One of the things you'll notice in your
work environment is that everybody's
workstation has a different set of
rights and permissions. That's because
we don't want to give administrative
access to everyone in the organization.
If malware or an attacker finds its way
onto one of those systems, they would
effectively have full access to all
devices on the network. Instead, we want
to provide just the right amount of
rights and permissions to allow someone
to do the work that they normally do. We
refer to this minimum set of rights and
permissions as least privilege. This
means that the user's access to data
should be limited to only what's
required to do their job, and any
applications that we're setting up will
run with those limited privileges.
Implementing lease privilege on your
network provides everyone with the
access they need to do their work, but
it also restricts any access by
malicious software or malicious
actors. One of the problems with many
organizations is that they put all of
their security on the border of their
network, leaving the inside of their
network very susceptible to any type of
attack. To address this issue, many
organizations are moving to a zerorust
implementation. This means that no
device on the network is trusted whether
it's outside the network or inside the
network. This means that every user,
every device, every application and
anything that happens inside of the
organization needs to be authenticated.
There needs to be a level of trust
associated with all of these devices
regardless of where they reside. This
means you'll find many organizations
implementing additional security
controls on the inside of their network
such as multiffactor authentication,
data encryption, perhaps the updating of
system permissions, adding additional
firewalls inside of the network, and
additional reporting and analytics on
everything that happens on the network
from a security
perspective. One common type of logical
security is an access control list or an
ACL. An access control list can be used
to allow or deny traffic through a
particular point on the network. We
commonly associate the term ACL with a
series of rules inside of a router
interface, but broadly an ACL can apply
to many different types of technology in
different areas of the network. A common
set of criteria that we often use with
ACL's are things like a source IP
address or destination IP address so
that we can determine whether that
traffic is allowed or denied based on
its source or destination. Perhaps we
evaluate the TCP port numbers, UDP port
numbers, whether this is the MP protocol
or some other type of protocol. We can
even combine these different criteria to
create a more complex ACL and create
more security on the network. Once we've
created the criteria, we also need to
create the disposition. Do we allow
traffic that matches this ACL or do we
deny this traffic? And we use ACL's in
many other parts of the network as well.
If you've ever configured rights and
permissions in a Linux operating system
or a Windows operating system, you have
effectively configured an access control
list. When you log into a service these
days, you're often asked for more than
just a username and a password. Those
additional factors are referred to as
multiffactor authentication. This
requires us to provide additional
information during the login process to
prove that we are really who we say we
are. For example, you may be logging
onto a system that asks you for a
password. That's something that you
know. You might also have to reference a
mobile app and provide the code that's
inside of that app. That's something we
have because the phone is something we
have to carry with us. And this app
might also require GPS location during
the authentication process to prove that
you really are nearby when you're
logging in. If you didn't have your
phone, you wouldn't be able to provide
the code. And if you were in a different
country, you would be providing a
different GPS location. We can very
broadly refer to these different factors
as something you know, something you
have, something you are, and somewhere
you are. In our example here, the
memorized password is something we know.
The mobile app and the code that it
provides is something we have. The
location of where we are is obviously
somewhere you are. And if we had to use
some type of biometric such as a
fingerprint, that would be something you
are. This is only an example of some of
the most popular factors. There are
other factors that could be used as
well. And combining these together allow
us to create a stronger authentication
process.
These days, it's very common to see
authentication use your email address as
one of those authentication factors. If
we use that email address during the
registration, it's common to also
receive a confirmation email in our
inbox. That way, we can click on that
message and confirm that the email we
provided during registration is
associated with an actual email address
and it's one that we know that we can
access. You might also find that this is
the only process used for
authentication. We provide our email
address. We have to wait to receive an
email confirmation and then by
confirming that email message, we're
allowed access into that service. These
services might also use that email for
additional capabilities. For example, if
you need to reset your password or
modify information that's in your
profile, they might require the email to
be able to confirm that process. This
email might also be used later for
additional verification. For example, if
we need to change a password or modify
part of our profile, it may ask us to
confirm that with an email
confirmation. In our discussion of
multiffactor authentication, I described
an app on your phone that provides you
with a code you need during the login
process. This is a very common way to
provide a pseudo random token generation
on a device that you carry around with
you wherever you go. If you don't have a
mobile phone, you could also use a
physical token generator that's
connected to your keychain. Most of us
know where our keys might be and
therefore we know where our token
generator is located. Since most of us
are carrying our phone around with us
anyway, having that token generation on
the phone is very convenient. And since
we have to authenticate to be able to
gain access to the app, it provides
another layer of security during the
authentication process.
Another factor commonly used during
authentication is to receive a text
message with that code. This is referred
to as the short message service or SMS.
During registration, you provide your
email address, your password, and also
your mobile phone number. When you log
in next time, you provide your username
and password. The system is going to
send you an SMS message on your phone,
and then you would use the code from
that SMS message to be able to complete
the login process. There are a number of
significant security problems with text
messaging as a factor of authentication.
One of them is that the phone number
you're using on your phone can be
reassigned to a different phone. This is
often done with social engineering where
the attacker will contact your phone
company and have them move that phone
number to the attacker's phone. This
means that the text messages that
normally would come to you would be
redirected to the attacker. Now the
attacker only needs your username and
your password and they can then use your
phone number to complete the login
process and gain access to your
account. Some authentication systems
will call you directly and speak the
number to you over the phone. So you
might receive a phone call and it says
your code is
162517. Then you have to type that in to
be able to complete the authentication
process. And as you're already aware,
having this type of authentication
associated with your phone number
creates a number of security problems.
Obviously, the phone call itself can be
redirected. Someone can easily forward
your phone to a different number. And
now all of your phone calls go to a
third-party telephone. This phone
number, of course, can also be added to
another phone. So instead of you
receiving this phone call, the phone
call instead goes to the attacker and
they now have the token required to log
in.
If you are using some type of token
generation program on your phone, you
may have one that has a code that
changes every 30 seconds or so. We refer
to this as a timebased one-time password
algorithm. The one-time password is the
one that is shown on the screen. And if
we add a timebased aspect to this, that
number will change after a certain
duration of time. This means that even
if we're not using the phone or looking
at the app, there is still a change to
the code every 30 seconds. This works by
having a secret key that is originally
configured both on the phone and the
authentication server. By keeping those
systems synchronized to the time of day,
both sides will know what the code
should be at any particular time. So
when you log in, you'll put in your
username, you'll put in your password,
and then you'll refer to the app to
determine what the pseudo random code
should be at that particular time of
day. This is probably one of the more
popular forms of one-time password
algorithm that you'll find. So if you're
using the Google authenticator, it's
using tootp. The same thing applies to
Facebook, Microsoft, and other
authentication types as well.
Sometimes synchronizing to the time of
day isn't possible. In that particular
case, you may just want to use an OTP
option. That is a one-time password
creation tool. This means that you'll
have an app that provides you with the
code and the next time you log in,
you'll use that code. Once you use that
code, you can discard it and then go to
the next code in the list that you'll
use for the next login process. Just
like the timebased one-time passwords,
the OTP process has a different token
every time. Since this is a seemingly
random number, it's effectively
impossible to guess what the next set of
numbers might be. And just like the
timebased systems, there are OTP apps
that you can use on your phone and
hardware tokens that you can connect to
your keychain. Either one of them will
work to provide you with a different key
each time you log into that system.